did you see the interview with Bill
Gates's ex-wife and she was being asked
about hey so
um Melinda you know you you we've read
and you've expressed that one of the
reasons why you know the marriage didn't
work out is the close relationship Bill
had with Jeffrey Epstein was that one of
the reasons she says uh yes it was
wondering
yes she said that was on the main
minutes yeah and then she says she
continued she says what was it that
upsets you about him is it the fact that
he had one too many visits to the island
she pauses she says
um yes but those are questions you're
going to have to ask him yeah so guess
what the answer they ask him and they
say so Bill right here do you have it uh
right there just gonna be tough yeah so
watch This Not That tough though because
she's crazy Rich
that Bill had a friendship or business
or some kind of contact with Jeffrey
Epstein and that you were not uh that
that was very upsetting to you did that
play a role in the in the divorce at all
in this process yeah as I said it's not
one thing it was many things that I did
not like uh that he'd had meetings with
Jeffrey Epstein
and you made that clear to him I made
that clear to him I also met Jeffrey
Epstein exactly
yes because I wanted to see who this man
was and
um I regretted it from the second I
stepped in the door he was abhorrent he
was evil personified I had nightmares
about it afterwards so my heart breaks
for these young women because that's how
I felt and here I'm an older woman my
God I feel terrible for those young
women it's awful you felt that the
moment you walked in 10 years old yeah
and you shared that with Bill and he
still continued to spend time with him
any of the questions remaining about
what Bill's relationship there was those
are for Bill to answer okay and I'll
tell you something about women women can
women I believe
can sense a bad dude like that okay you
feel it my mother's amazing at that my
mother I'm telling you has antenna my
mother has saved my dad from going into
business deals really dude
she she can look at a dude and go that
guy's a bad guy I got a bad feeling wow
and that's how women had to survive I
think women can pick up on energy that
we don't because we're not afraid I
don't you know I don't walk around
worrying about my physical safety but
there are women I think women are way
better the the Israelis use women as uh
as bodyguards because they found that if
you take you can teach a woman how to
shoot straight no problem and there are
some badass women so they they found
that women they grow up from the age
about 12 years old they have to be I
wait I see it with my daughter they're
very aware of danger they're very aware
why is that guy over there why is he
looking at me for too long what's going
over here they can just sense these
things okay I read um I read I wrote um
a pilot with a woman long time ago who
who was ran a brothel I wanted to do
this thing it was called the rub Club
but she was amazing because she would
say that when they would come in she
would hug a guy so she would hug so the
guy come in hourglass she would hug him
yeah
she would hug him and then her friend
would hug the guy from behind and be
like hi and what they were doing was
checking for weapons wow
right so you push your body against him
make sure he doesn't have a gun or not
because you're gonna get robbed or
whatever that's the first thing they
would do the second thing they would do
is this woman could tell immediately if
this guy's a freak she could tell
immediately if he was dangerous all of
them could because they had so much
experience with this like the way he
walked in was he moving his arms was he
very stiff was his body what was his
body temperature so you know when
somebody like like Melinda Gates sees a
guy like that and she goes I had a bad
feeling man listen to that my mother my
dad was going to go into business with
this guy right and uh you know they're
playing golf and the guy
nobody was looking and he kicked this
ball oh now I cheated golf
all the time and I'm gonna lie about my
score 100 but you're gonna know I'm
lying You're Gonna See Me cheat I'm not
gonna actually go I'm not gonna this guy
looked around and just went he just
touched it like that my mother saw that
my mother goes if you put this money
into this deal I'm gonna divorce you
what are we talking about she goes I
watched him cheat and he goes everybody
cheat to go off he goes no nobody cheats
when they're really trying to get away
with it anyway long story short he ended
up in jail
I think we're referring to him as
women's intuition they do have that
sense and I think you highlighted it is
that as guys if we're going into
business with somebody or networking
somebody's yeah whatever bro I'm a dude
whatever yeah a girl literally one she
walks out the door like we do the whole
okay phone wallet keys balls got it all
right good to go girls like all right I
got my mace I've got my purse like
there's another level that women have to
go to for Safety and Security and that
intuition since caveman days has to be a
part of it great point and you know it
yeah here's my question though so she
this this happened fairly recent right
but the Epstein thing he already
killed suicided himself in jail
everything what do you think was her
motivation to finally because dude this
relationship with Epstein was way back
in the day what what do you think was
the the deciding factor for her to say
let me open my mouth now because what
they got galane and she might open her
mouth or what first of all you're
thinking getting a divorce is easy what
do you think a divorce is you think a
divorce is uh like okay yeah you know no
problem like a breakup we're good we're
good score it away all right all the
best to you bro okay tell your mom
awesome love their cooking but uh I'm
sorry man you know this it is what it is
and my dad's gonna miss you you know he
loves you good luck I'll see you at the
you know whatever casual divorce ever
but but divorces you know take years
before a divorce happens when a divorce
happens a divorce been in the works for
five years okay three years eight years
sometimes ten years right uh uh you know
uh how many times like I'll I'll sit in
over the years we run an insurance
company so we we see a lot of people
being married and some that work
sometimes don't work 22 years you watch
these guys and haven't been married for
13 and a half years myself four kids
families you know that that's a very
hard thing to do but you'll see
if uh there is kids involved if there's
a charity involved and they do there's
you know business involved if there is
uh uh other responsibilities involved if
there's certain legacies involved if
there's dirt on both sides involved if
there is it's it's a very uh it's you
know what it's like it's kind of like a
business partners you start a company
together with your best friend hey
Johnny let's do it 50 50 bro let's go
take over the world awesome then you
start the business and then six months
into it he's like hey bro I just want to
let you know I'm going to take the month
of August off because uh the wife and I
we want to go to such and such what do
you mean yeah bro I mean I'm gonna go
dude what are you talking about we just
started the business I know but it's our
business I'm gonna take all this stuff
and then I'm for Christmas and New
Year's we're going to Davos you know to
go there for vacation
so then you're like all right hey by the
way I think uh we need to hire that two
person because you spend 300 000 so hire
two Executives dude that's a waste of
money why would we do that a year two
years later like oh I made the
biggest mistake of my life your best
friend officially became your best enemy
but try breaking up to 50 50. good luck
you know how many mediations I've done
as a consultant between two business
partners really we had one upstairs uh
just a couple months ago they're sitting
it's just like a marriage divorce so I
said so can I do something here yes I
said first of all tell me what you
respect and why you guys went into
business together so I write it down
you'll feel the same way yeah okay what
got to the point of you guys not wanting
to be in business together
can you tell them exactly how you feel
do you receive it can you tell them
exactly how you found them zero to 100
in no time and then they're gone they're
going they're going and you got to try
to figure out it will bring them down
and say can we get it on paper right now
that these are the terms this is what
we're agreeing on lawyers boom boom boom
boom boom you're hoping one is willing
to sell at 1.2 million dollars his
shares to the other gun the guy's gonna
run with it or hey I'm Gonna Leave You
keep it I'm gonna start a direct
competitor to you and you cannot come
after me and we're gonna and I'm taking
three of the employees you can keep
everybody else it is very very ugly 50
50 Partnerships are very hard to break
apart divorces are the same exact way so
this divorce with Melinda and Bill
probably was in the works for 15 years
do you know how they did it do you know
do you know the process I hope I'm not
speaking on a turn but I think I can say
it um so uh his best friend they got on
a boat together all of them all three of
them and with his best friend and they
basically the best friend mediated the
whole thing on a boat in the middle of
the ocean Bill and Melinda Gates and the
best of us correct sir that is that is
good for them so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]